ma già fa caldo vi aiuterò a capire come
introdurre questa cosa per far già oggi
sono qua con pietro perché facciamo un
test che ci riguarda particolarmente
innanzitutto vi dico che l'ho vista
dagli annuncia nel quadro visto detto
gatto proprio una roba fatta per me
dietro quel calcola il tuo livello di
stupida apparentemente letto uno scritto
che tipo fare sta roba ti fa fare un
test della stupidità tenuto sono tante
domande bisogna saper leggere pro del
villaggio dava pace l'uno grazie per
calcolare l'adottabilità abbiamo deciso
di tirare una piccola ditta di roba
interessante che tu quella è compiuto
nella tua vita sono ste capace di
contare avranno cominciare nemmeno noi
siamo capaci ma sappi che le ricadute
per stupida cento per cento negli anni
la finta che qualche tempo prima di
rijeka non negando alla bocca mentre
parla di che mai successo ha voglia
ingoiare chewing gum l'avevano l'arcano
e salute con una strada sbagliata vai a
sbattere contro una porta o qualcosa di
trasparente io ieri che lo metta chiama
due volte lo stesso numero non lo so
vediamo nei primi sei sbagliato
no non ho mai fatto ma l'operaio fatto
fiume stefano nomination è stato deve
pensare qualcosa di divertente rieter ad
alta voce per scoprire che per questo
pre capitano sbatte contro alberi
cartelloni banca evidente la morte le
forza capire cabine telefoniche mentre
capirossi mentre si sa i morti cammino
una volta si portava di qua
e da quella volta che ti credi alla
battere contro alberi che sarà tutto di
prima di poterti leccare florido l'ho
fatto una volta quindi mettiamo bastardo
si era fatto male e dopo aver letto la
precedente il destinatario baia la mega
appena ricordati dove hai parcheggiato
vuoi morire viola non è anche la patente
quindi almeno a cucinare lo zucchero
nella parata vantarne pensare alimenti
nel posto sbagliato olio di kevin
analizzata diviene di third party fine
di idee grafico di nove la facile
accesso immediato e non farà mai
io aggiungo una io indossare le cuffie
in un gameplay dove l'oceano ha cercato
di condanna che gli è accanto una
persona che non conosci no porta modiano
dormire in classe anche ad occhi aperti
gli occhi di gaber o le vicine che non
abbiamo sultano uscirebbe un menù
raccontare qualcosa dimenticati c'è
sempre una che gameplay a questa
raccontare una balla dimenticate venendo
scoperti
io no proprio quello stronzo che so
per prima cosa usare le dita per fare
ditemi tempi vabbè in prima elementare
ovvio che ho io quando facevo tipo alle
espressioni lunghe volante due più due
lo facevo per essere sicuri di tutto io
do calcolo per tagliare la fermata
dell'autobus perché non ci si accordi
che già passata pensa che notaio rosa
solo dell'autobus e cielo solo gli ormai
all'auto spettacolo di sarah era solo io
e le località di porto che sono allo
spoleto non è quindi te lo so io devo
tornare io per andare a comprare la
carta entrare in acqua perdere costume
quando non è legato bene di scrivere
ripetutamente belvedere per scrivere di
malta mente frasi o parole queste parole
che non sono italiani la linea luogo cui
l'onda marina batte la spiaggia che
detta barchino bagnasciuga po in patria
l'ugl organo parla come come vai al mare
entrate ufficio sbagliata ibrido bacall
e oggetti nel pattern ma anche
volutamente o involontariamente
involontariamente tutte e due
io provare ibra li pregiate c'è in
ognuno era piccolo da sole valide ai
plettri mancano le batte accendere poco
sotto una pentola penta acqua nel bagno
io lo faccio apposta perché il bagno
delle donne più pulito pari dei top
perchè non vai qual è il tuo sesso no ma
dai video essere in una nave guardare il
mare perdere gli occhiali no longer
targa euro di nuovo il tacco andare ora
mentre in mano qualcosa o rovesciando
andare in giro punto 7 cosa da poco una
vicina no non me ne freghi pila
legamenti critiche sono contentissimo
lasciare la macchina senza freno a mano
e correre per recuperarla nome non mica
quanto rifila rai o accendere la
sigaretta dal lato sbagliato eventuale
no fu la mamma che irride chiamare la
maestra chiamare maestro mamma non
dentro forse no no
ormai sembra la tua ragazza come lei
fina nota no era successo demonio
tornare alla propria macchina partecipa
che fanno le domande sulla macchina che
non ce l'ho provata semidistrutta piange
accorgersi che il museo dell'auto è
uguale malta cli car
abbiamo allora perché in percentuale
recuperato un po alla fine proprio per
fare risultato
hai ottenuto 63 punti livello di
stupidità il recuperabile ma che te lo
dico a fare troppo stupido per capire
quello sto cercando di dirti non è mica
una sorella la presenza in questo video
vi sia piaciuto dipinto lo penso anch'io
andare un complimento ogni tanto mi
danno del famiglia trovarelli capacità
reattiva 32 giornate mi piace anche lei
come stata un artigiano rivisiterà cbta
ragazzi
[Musica]
m